hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
will heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie
ich meine butterplätzchen mache ich
wusste gar nicht dass da so der bedarf
da ist für dieses video weil ich immer
dachte das eigentlich jedes rezept für
butterplätzchen kennt aber anscheinend
gibt es da wirklich noch unterschiede
und einige haben mich gefragt indem man
es dem hinbekommt dass die plätzchen
richtig schön zart werden und deswegen
möchte ich euch heute meine konzept
vorstellen
ich kenne zwei varianten wie man das
machen kann und zwar gibt es bei
mürbeteig einmal die 123 methode und
einmal die andere methode die ich euch
gleich zeigen werde
die 123 methode finde ich ganz gut man
kann sie sich gut merken und gerade für
kinder zum beispiel ist es eine gute
alternative
man muss dann einfach ein teil zucker
hat zwei teile fett und 3 teile mail und
bisher dachte ich immer dass das ein
sehr einfaches rezept ist aber das
rezept was ich euch gleich zeigen welche
ist aber noch einfacher weil wir da so
einfach nichts mehr recht also nicht
mehr so viel rechnen muss und zwar ist
es die 21 05 methode und zwar nicht
unter einfach zwei teile mähen einen
teil und ein hallenteil zucker und für
mich hat sich dieses rezept es besser
herauskristallisiert weil man auch
weniger fett und weniger zucker in der
gesamtmasse hat und weil die bläschen
dadurch richtig schön locker und richtig
feiern werden ich habe jetzt hier 600
gramm mehl dann die hälfte davon butter
also 300 gramm
die hälfte davon zucker also 150 gramm
und dann rechne ich etwa ein eigelb pro
50 gramm zucker also sind jetzt hier 3
eigelb und ich habe jetzt hier noch eine
gute prise salz
ihr könnt natürlich auch etwas
backpulver hinzufügen oder etwas vanille
zucker oder andere aromen aber ich
möchte dass die kekse fest bleiben
deswegen möchte ich jetzt kein
backpulver und wer deswegen jetzt auch
keine aromen hinzufügen weil ich ganz
einfache butterplätzchen
ganz einfach finde ich es wenn man den
mürbeteig ihren der thermomix macht oder
per hand knetet aber auch mit der
kitchenaid finde ich den super so kann
ich nämlich zuerst zucker und butter
etwas verrühren kann dann mehl und die
eier hinzufügen und auch direktes und
kann dann mit dem knethaken das mehl
einarbeiten
als ich defizit zuerst die butter
reingeht dann noch das salz mit dazu und
dann gebe ich dann nach und nach der
zucker mit treiben lassen schön
einarbeiten
wenn das ganze so schön für dich kommt
noch das eigelb mit dazu
hat sich da der zucker schon bisher
aufgelöst das ist ganz gut
jetzt nehme ich den krebs entsteht hier
noch das mehl mit dazu
dann nehmt ihr euch einfach den teig
raus selbst ein bisschen gruselig weil
der hat ja weniger unter 123 betreibt
und am beste fed ihr euch eure hände
tesla mit butter und knetet den teig von
schön so die kugel zusammen
mädel allzu weit habt könnt ihr ihnen in
der schüssel geben und mit etwas folie
abdecken und dann geht's mit den teig am
besten für eine nacht in den kühlschrank
so kann sich nämlich dass zucker richtig
schön drin lösen und dann kann man ihn
zu bearbeiten
im prinzip könnte die zutat noch einfach
einmal komplett miteinander verkneten
aber der vorteil ist wenn man die butter
zuerst mit dem zucker etwas verwirrt
dass der teig daneben feiner wird und
lockerer und der teig muss danach in den
kühlschrank damit sich da eben der
zucker richtig lösen kann unter zeigt
sich ausruhen kann und dann lässt dass
ich am nächsten halt wirklich super
verarbeiten und ihr bekommt richtig
tolle kekse hin falls diese zeit nicht
habt um den teig etwas stehen zu lassen
können da zum beispiel aber auch
puderzucker benutzen dann las er ihn
einfach für 12 stunden im kühlschrank
und dann können gleich weiterverarbeiten
ich werde ich jetzt einfach mal zeigen
was so die tipps und tricks beim
ausrollen sind wie es plätzchen richtig
gleichmäßig hin bekommt und wie ihr sie
ihn dann backen ist und dazu zeige ich
euch einfach mal wie ich schneeflocken
kekse mache und seht ihr jetzt gleich
nach dem kühlschrank ist der teig
natürlich steht fest und am besten lasst
ihr den etwa 1 stunde noch kompakter
stehen und steigt es auch am besten wege
den teig portioniert und eben nicht
alles auf einmal macht also das noch
richtig hart
und jetzt dieses stück hier etwas
verkneten und den teig einfach so weit
verkneten dass er nicht mehr bröselt
aber immer noch schön kalt ist und jetzt
nehme ich mir meinen silikon aus
rollstuhl und per mail denn neid und
möchte den teig jetzt richtig gleich
ausrollen und dafür habe ich hier so
zwei abstandshalter das sind so klein
holzstäbe und da steht jetzt eine 5
drauf das steht für 5 mm
die gibt es eben jeder dicke und die
links zu den einzelnen artikeln schreibe
ich euch in die infobox
das gute an dem stil ikone starb ich
einfach dass er einfach zu reinigen ist
und das einfach kein teil hängen bleibt
genauso wie bei der city wohnpark mathe
kann das hier hoch nehmen aber ganz gut
ist wenn ihr natürlich eine zweite matte
habt dann könnt ihr darüber legen das
ganze einmal stürzen geht aber auch
super mit euren back folien und dann
braucht ihr ganz wenig mehl nur
unterteilt wird eben nicht so trocken
jetzt habe ich hier schon so eine kleine
auswahl an eiskristallen und
schneeflocken und ist in ausstecher aus
edelstahl
dies sind rostfrei und ich finde bei
denen lohnt sich die anschaffung die
kauft muss ich dann einmal und die gehen
euch dann auch nicht kaputt wichtig ist
nur dass ihr die ausgedehnten per hand
waschen und nicht in der spülmaschine
oder spülmaschinen fällen also alles was
mir am herzen liegt spüre ich am
nächsten mit der hand weil ich einfach
weiß dass es durch diese nicht so sehr
angegriffen wird jetzt könnte hier die
stets einfach ausstechen wenn sie gleich
mit rausgehen nehmt das ihr euch mit und
setzt sie gleich auf ein backblech
unternehme ich mir einfach so ein
kleines werkzeug und den teig vorsichtig
auszudrücken weil gerade bei den
filigranen formen ist sehr schwierig und
jetzt nehmt euch am besten sonderwünsche
palette ich könnte hier den teig schön
anheben
ohne dass euch die kekse kaputt gehen
und dann kann man auch gleich rüber
setzen
wichtig ist jetzt beim backen dass ihr
die großen und die kleinen kekse
voneinander trennt weil die kleinen
kekse nur sehr wenig zeit brauchen und
die großen kekse eben der längere
parkzeit haben und jetzt ist es auch
ganz wichtig damit die kekse schön so in
form bleiben
gibt es denn nochmal in den kühlschrank
ich würde sagen so etwa für eine halbe
stunde damit dateien wieder richtig kalt
wird und ihr die kekse dann richtig kalt
in den ganz heißen ofen gibt damit sie
schön eben ihre form behalten und nicht
so nach außen zerlaufen
wenn ihr plätzchen machen wollte und die
später mit marmelade befüllen wollt dann
stellt ihr euch zwei gleiche plätzchen
aus und müssten eines noch ein loch
reinstecken das könnte entweder mit
einer lochtiefe von einem spritzbeutel
machen oder ihn in einen kleineren
ausstecher das mache ich jetzt mit diese
und dazu lege ich die plätze also die
kekse schon auf das backpapier damit es
dann beim abheben nicht kaputt geht und
dann sehe ich das mittelteil hier raus
und das könnte ihnen gleichzeitig auch
als plätzchen backen und eben mit
verhalten und die kleinen plätzchen und
die plätzchen mit dem ausgestochenen
löchern die kann ich jetzt auf einem
backblech packen weil die eben ungefähr
die gleiche backzeit haben aber die
plätzchen ohne noch die großen dichter
natürlich separate
die kleinen kekse die haben mir fünf
minuten gebacken und die lasse ich jetzt
hier auch schön abkühlen
wenn ihr die plätzchen marmelade filmen
wollt nehmt euch einfach eine lieblings
marmelade
ich nehme immer ganz gern hin bei
konfitüren die gebe ich mir jetzt in
kleinen teller und möchte sie in der
mikrowelle erwärmen
ihr könnt es aber auch ganz gut im topf
machen aber in der mikrowelle geht bei
mir einfach schneller und sobald es dann
ein bisschen warm ist und etwas
flüssiger ist erreicht es hier auch
schon dann lebt ihr das in einen
spritzbeutel ich nehme dazu immer gern
einwegspritze burgen dann verschließe
ich denen da oben und jetzt kann ich da
oben eine kleine spitze abschneiden
und neben mir einen keks und dann gebe
ich die marmelade auf diesen keks drauf
das ist alles sehr vorsichtig machen und
auch nicht bis ganz zum rand dann bis
später damit einfach ausgewählt und dann
kommt da der keks drauf
und jetzt müsste das gleich mit etwas
puderzucker bestäuben
weil nämlich so die mama rate noch warm
ist und dann der puderzucker auf der
marmelade schmelzen wird so dass dann
der puderzucker hier nicht mehr zu sehen
ist es möchten ihr könnt euch aber auch
überlegen den keks versetzt darauf zu
geben das heißt die marmelade kommt nur
hier in die mitte und dann gebt ihr da
den keks ganz vorsichtig wir drauf na
gut das muss ich hier eben noch die
ecken und kanten befüllen
und so sehen dann die fertigen plätzchen
mit marmeladen füllung aus die müssen
jetzt schön abkühlen und damit auch die
marmelade hier wieder fest stapeln würde
ich die allerdings nicht also wenn ihr
die aufbewahren wollte würde ich sie
alle nebeneinander legen gleich etwas
backpapier dazwischen und dann können
dass sie eventuell versetzt stapeln
aber so marmeladen kekse sind eigentlich
nicht so gut zum schlafen geeignet wenn
ihr eure kekse lieber mit zitronen die
aktion verzieren wollt nehmt ihr euch
etwas puderzucker und zitrone
ich hab jetzt ihr drei esslöffel
puderzucker und geht hier den
zitronensaft mit dazu da nehme ich erst
mal einen esslöffel zitronensaft dann
wird das ganze verrührt nächste einfach
gucken wie die konsistenz eben sein soll
das soll kein flüssiger fuß werden
und den könnt ihr euch jetzt
beispielsweise mit einem pinsel auf eure
plätzchen drauf geben
ihr könnt dann aber auch vorher ein
vergehen das werde ich jetzt mal machen
und zwar mit einem hellen blau weil ich
ja jetzt hier die schneekristalle und
eiskristalle dekorieren möchte und dazu
nehme ich ein bisschen passten farbe
nimmt der himmel blau gebe eine ganz
kleine spitzen oder rein
und wie gesagt könnt ihr das entweder
mit pinsel drauf machen oder mit einem
spritzbeutel und ganz perfekt könnt ihr
dann arbeiten wenn ihr eine kleine lok
kühle dafür benutzt und wird die kleine
loch schule braucht ihr einen kleinen
adapter und dafür müsst ihr die spritze
erstmal aufschneiden und zwar so dass
oben der hals zweieinhalb zentimeter
weit offen ist dagegen ankommen linearen
dran und legt mir das hier auf meiner
arbeitsplatz und kann das hier schwingen
unter schneiden und dann habe ich da die
perfekte größe und wenn ihr mich diesen
adaptern und spritztouren arbeitet habt
ihr einfach den vorteil dass ihr die
spritztour austauschen könnt während dem
arbeiten und nicht in den kompletten
beute wieder auswechseln müsst und ich
nehme jetzt natürlich mit zwei
millimetern durchmesser und schraubt die
hier oben drauf mit dieser schritt tun
könnte jetzt richtig exakt arbeiten und
es darauf spritzen
und wenn es hier am rand noch ganz exakt
haben will kann das auch mit einem
zahnstocher hier ausziehen das richtige
spitzen sind
und zu sehen meine fertigen kekse aus
ich habe jetzt noch viel mehr kekse
ausgestorben
ich werde euch einfach in den nächsten
tagen in mehreren videos einfach mal
zeigen wie ich diese kekse dekoriert
damit ihr euch das so richtig vorstellen
könnt in den videos zeige ich euch da
nicht mal wieder hergestellt wird das
habt ihr jetzt in diesem video gesehen
und ich wünsche euch jetzt einfach viel
spaß bei der keksproduktion viel spaß
beim backen
falls ich das video gefallen hat dann
teils mit euren freunden geht mir eine
bewertung über den kommentar freut mich
auch immer und dann sehen wir schon beim
nächsten mal wieder bis bald
m